London gateway port a symbol of
Britain's role in global trade ships
come here from 60 different countries
around the world but what happens next
what will be the rules for all these
imports and exports in the future it is
a fundamental question about brexit many
are now promoting the idea of the UK
leaving the EU but staying on as a
member of the European customs union
that's similar to Turkey's relationship
with the EU it would mean a trade
agreement that removes all taxes on
goods as they travel around Europe what
that means is that the goods within
these containers can be sent to France
or Germany they can be unpacked and
distributed across Europe and then the
containers can be refilled and sent back
here to the UK all without any extra
taxes being imposed so could a customs
union be the answer to the biggest
brexit headache of all the prospect of a
return to an obtrusive physical border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic well a customs union would mean
that you could get rid of checks on
tariffs between the countries but it
wouldn't end the need for some kind of
legal border because the Republic of
Ireland would be in the European single
market and Northern Ireland wouldn't a
customs union is a necessary component
of dealing with the issue of the Irish
land border but it's far from sufficient
what we're talking about in order to
deal with the Irish land border is close
regulatory alignment so there's no need
to check some for example products of
animal origin Soviet land milk or beef
but there are other issues to deal with
the customs union hampers the UK's
ability to sign individual trade deals
an alternative which would allow the UK
to sign bespoke trade deals to send
goods like that off around the world is
called common market 2.0 it's a pretty
soft form of brexit loved by some hated
by others but support for it is growing
this idea would see the UK remain in the
single market and
to strike its own trade deals with the
rest of the world but it would require
us to accept freedom of movement and to
continue to pay into the EU budget this
idea is similar to Norway's relationship
with the EU it's a member of the
European single market but opts out of
the customs union that's why you'll find
hard border checks between Norway and
Sweden which is an EU country if we were
not in a customs union and we were just
talking about being the single market
similar to how Iceland is or Norway is
then you are able to negotiate trade
agreements pretty much the only solely
focused on goods and those countries
have done so Iceland for example has a
trade agreement with China the question
is whether we prioritize trade with our
nearest neighbors or go for fast-growing
markets on the other side of the world
the answer to that will determine what
sort of trade do we pursue Adam Parsons
Sky News London gateway